at least 21 people have been killed and
42 others
injured in an attack on a prison in
eastern afghanistan
officials say there were several
explosions including a suicide car bomb
outside the prison in the city of
janalabad afghan security forces are
locked in a gun battle with the
attackers
several prisoners escaped during the
fighting isil claimed responsibility
the national security analyst and
founding member of transparency
afghanistan he joins us now from kabul
good to have you with us so
why the attack on a prison in ka on
janalabad
um well so the responsibility of the
attack has been claimed by the islamic
state
and it's believed that you have a vast
amount of um
daesh or isl members who are
imprisoned in this very prison so if
daesh has taken responsibility
the primary motive could be to make sure
that
to sort of release um their prisoners
and this is what they have done the
initial reports that we have is
that there are about 1 500 prisoners
in the prison and 500 of them have been
able to escape
which the government claims that they
have they were able to
um sort of capture them all after they
evaded the prison and they are
um and uh they have been captured um all
over again
so the primary motive just like i said
could be that the daesh
uh wanted to have its members out of the
prison
daesh is jalalabad is located in eastern
afghanistan
this is where the um strongholds of
daesh were since 2014 2015.
kunar province nuristan province
lachmann province
and then nangara province is this
eastern
area where you had the presence of
daesh and this is where majority of
their prisoners
are kept and perhaps they wanted to
infiltrate
and have their prisoners released what
does this say then about the ability and
status
of isil daesh as you say
if this is indeed their work
so there are two messages that could be
um
sort of taken from what has happened in
jalalabad
one is that you've had numerous press
statements press releases
speeches of various government officials
this includes president ghani this
includes
um the national security adviser over
and over
sort of bragging about the defeat of
daesh in afghanistan
and how the afghan government have done
so well
and eliminating eradicating and
uprooting the phenomena of daesh
and what has happened today is basically
contradicting the claims of the african
government
daesh has proven that they have ability
to inflict damage
to the african government inflict damage
where
and the heart of one of afghanistan's
major
and important urban centers called
jalalabad
the other message that is being passed
on is that the
united states of america the african
government
and the taliban are basically a step
short of starting the intra-afghan
negotiations
the other message could be um right here
is that
it's not just the taliban you have other
elements
which are basically of a huge threat to
the
um survival of the african national
security forces
is just not the um taliban you also have
daesh it's also a force to reckon with
um so if you basically get into an
agreement with the taliban
what's going to happen um to the future
or
the fate of daesh because just like the
government has claimed that they have
taken
care of daesh they have been uprooted
and what they have done in jalalabad is
totally contradicting each other all
right thanks so much good to get your
analysis happy birthday